[Music]
frank is in venice florida hi frank
welcome to the ramsay show
yes sir you always put a big old smile
on my face mr ramsay well thank you sir
how can we help
i've got a lovely home
to a pickle um
my girlfriend was paralyzed and i
brought daughter into my house and had
to gut the house and buy no doors and
put a mother-in-law's feet on the side
for somebody to take care of her and all
this and put a hundred thousand dollars
more in the house and now uh
she got her money and went on which is
fine
and i i'm stuck with a house that's uh
priced at 100 and tops is 190 in the
neighborhood and i was trying to ask
8289 and i'm not getting any bites and i
don't know
uh should i keep it and try to
rent it but with the rent thing i won't
rent it so it's been empty for like two
years and i just i'm kind of in in the
price of housing once it goes down it's
gonna mobile homes get hit and you have
to pay cash for it so the this whole
thing this the the addition all of its
mobile home
pardon me the the whole deal is a mobile
home i thought you said you did like an
audition
i did yeah yeah yeah and it's what you
do attach a different mobile home to it
i don't understand no no no it's
the i bought it that way the uh carport
area has a huge long carport and they
took that side of it and put up
another
mother-in-law suite on the side
and so the whole structure
is mobile home
you have to walk down two stairs and
then you're down in the other part of
the it's like the ground floor on the
garage level
for the other part of it a basement
sort of speak it's the garage i mean
there's there's a garage on the other
side of the door where you can put your
car in or your motorcycle so okay but i
mean this there's not any portion of
this home of this property that is
traditionally stick built it's all uh no
manufactured housing
and so you think that the actual market
value on it regardless of what you paid
for it if you put on the market and said
i'm going to sell this to a real person
for real money
the the real market value is what
i had a
lady come out and she said it was
anywhere in the neighborhood
she priced it out for anywhere from 120
to 190. and uh it's all wheelchair
accessible it has a deck dock on the
water double lot
three huge sheds concrete all the way
around the house everything's macked out
and all the furniture goes with it it's
ready to go what kind of water is it on
intercoastal or what
uh fresh water goes up to two lakes okay
all right just access all right
um
and is is there you said it was a
neighborhood or an area that is worth
how in the hundred thousand dollar range
though
well the the the realtor said it goes
anywhere from 120 to 190 in that
neighborhood well that's ridiculous i
mean 120 to 190 why why didn't you say
50 to a million my god i mean i know i
know that's that's what i i'd like so i
think you need a different yeah
yeah click on elp at ramsey solutions
and get one of our endorsed local
providers out there to look at this
thing um it sounds to me like it sounds
to me like what you said is true
um that you have
you spent a lot of money to build a
situation
to build a situation out that you're not
going to recoup
like i'm like she had nowhere to go so i
got in my house yeah i paid people
trades them to come out i know but
you're well now
i'm not saying you had bad motivation
and that you're not noble you are noble
and you had a wonderful motivation but
the end of the story today is
or the end of the next chapter is
today i'm sitting here with a piece of
property that regardless of how we got
here that we have way too much invested
in based on what it's really
worth yes sir yeah that's what i mean
how do i sell to a handicapped person
and then they would love the house they
just have to find the right person yeah
you gotta you gotta put on the market
and it doesn't necessarily have to be a
handicap it just has some have to have
somebody that just really doesn't want
two levels it could be just somebody
doesn't want to climb stairs anymore
right and they like the water
and they like the big garage and the
carport and all that that's all cool you
know
and so i i don't care why they like it i
just want them to like it and give you
money for it
right and you're going to lose money
when you do this because you have more
than 120 in it don't you
oh my god
i got over 300 in it yeah so you're that
part's just screwed you understand that
yeah that's why i was asking 289 and
i've had 25 people to do come through
the house it's a beautiful house but
it's it's priced out of the neighborhood
we only want to spend 200. i'm like uh
but
you'll never find one like this yeah we
know but yeah but you're priced out of
the neighborhood see what what you what
you paid for it doesn't matter
what you'd like to get for it doesn't
matter what someone what someone will
actually pay you for it is all that
matters that's called market value
right that's what they're saying and
this is this is the part of the story
where you admit that what you did even
though it was of good
intention and a very noble call
cost you 200 grand
what were they supposed to do you know
yeah that's it i'm not i didn't i didn't
say you did anything
but you wrote a check
to be noble
for 200 grand that's the net effect of
this and the sooner you get past the
idea that somehow you're going to get
more money for this because you were a
great guy taking care of her i'm sorry
it doesn't enter into the equation of
market value
there's no part of the real estate
valuation that says great guy yeah and i
don't know how much equity you know
frank's got in this thing or what he
could sell it for what he get out of it
where he's going to go next those are
some pieces of equation he's got to
figure out but the key here is and you
talk about this in financial peace
university and the real estate lesson is
not overbuilding in the neighborhood and
it's for exactly this reason because
you're underwater on it like you would
be with a car and so frank uh i think
you've got some hard decisions to make
but i think this is a stupid tax yeah
you've already lost the money the only
question is are you going to admit it
that the money's gone
you're not going to get it back out of
this property
and
when you sell it and you get a check for
125 000
that's when you will admit it
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with it again i'm not picking on you for
your motives or anything else uh you
know looking back on it you probably
would have done it a different way if i
were to ask you that but completely
understand